mr speaker i
beg to move that a humble address be
presented to her majesty
expressing the deepest sympathies of
this house on the death of his royal
highness
the prince philip duke of edinburgh and
the heartfelt thanks of this house
and this nation for his unfailing
dedication to this country
and the commonwealth exemplified in his
distinguished service in the royal navy
in the second world war his commitment
to young people
in setting up the duke of edinburgh's
award a scheme which has touched
the lives of millions across the globe
his early passionate commitment to the
environment and his unstinting support
to your majesty throughout his life
mr speaker it is fitting that on
saturday his raw highness the duke of
edinburgh
will be conveyed to his final resting
place
in a land rover which prince philip
designed himself
with a long wheelbase and capacious rear
cabin
because that vehicle's unique and
idiosyncratic silhouette
reminds the world that he was above all
a practical man
who could take something very
traditional
whether a machine or indeed
a great national institution
and find a way by his own ingenuity
to improve it to adapt it
for the 20th and the 21st century
that gift for innovation was apparent
from his earliest career
in the navy when he served in the second
world war he was mentioned
in dispatches for his alertness and
appreciation of the situation
during the battle of cape matapan and he
played a crucial role
in helping to sink two enemy cruisers
but it was later during the invasion of
sicily
that he was especially remembered by his
crewmates for what he did
to save their own ship
in a moment of high danger at night
when hms wallace was vulnerable to being
blown up by
enemy planes he improvised a floating
decoy
complete with fires to make it look like
a stricken british vessel
so that the wallace was able to slip
away and the enemy
took out the decoy he was there at tokyo
bay
in 1945 barely 200 yards away from the
japanese surrender
on the deck of uss missouri
but he wasn't content just to watch
history through his binoculars
it seems that he used the lao to get on
with repainting the hull
of hms wealth and throughout his life
a life that was of necessity wrapped
from such a young age in symbol and
ceremony
one can see that same instinct to look
for what was most useful
for the most practical and what would
take things
forward he was one of the first people
in this country
to use a mobile phone in the 1970s he
was driving
an electric taxi on the streets of
london
the forerunner of the modern low-carbon
fleet and again
a vehicle of his own specifications
he wasn't content just to be a carriage
driver
he played a large part in pioneering
and codifying the sport of competitive
carriage driving avid is if it is true
mr speaker that carriage driving is not
a mass participation sport
not yet he had other
novel ideas that touched the lives of
millions
developed their character and confidence
their teamwork
and self-reliance it was
amazing and instructive to listen on
friday to the cabinet's tributes
to the duke and to hear how many of them
were proud to say that they
or their children had benefited from
taking part in his duke of edinburgh
award schemes i will leave it to the
house to speculate as to who claimed
to have got a gold award and who got a
bronze
but i believe those ministers spoke for
millions
around the world across this country who
felt that the duke had in some way
touched
their lives people whose work he
supported
in the course of an astonishing 22
219 public engagements
people he encouraged and people yes
that he amused it is true
that he occasionally drove a coach and
horses through the finer points of
diplomatic protocol
and he coined a new word donto pedology
for the experience of putting your foot
in your mouth
when he spoke so feelingly about the
problems of overpopulation and
humanity's relentless incursion on the
natural world
and the consequent destruction of
habitat and species
he contrived to be at once politically
incorrect
and also ahead of his time
in a quite unparalleled career of advice
and encouragement and support he
provided one particular service
that i believe we in the house know
in our hearts was the very greatest
of all in the constant love he gave to
her majesty the queen
as her liege man of life and limb in the
words he spoke at the coronation
he sustained her throughout this
extraordinary second elizabethan age now
the longest reign of any monarch in our
history
it was typical of him that in wooing her
majesty
famously not short of a duel or two
he offered jewelry of his own design he
dispensed with the footman
in powdered wigs he introduced
television cameras
and at family picnics and balmoral he
would barbecue
the sausages on a large metal
contraption
that all prime ministers must have
goggled at for decades
complete with rotisserie and
compartments
for the sources that was once again mr
speaker
a product of his own invention and
creation
indeed as an advocate of skills
and craft and science and technology
this country has had no royal champion
to match him since prince albert
and i know that in due course the house
in the country will want to consider
a suitable memorial to prince philip
it is with that same spirit of
innovation
that is cogent of the royal family he
shaped and protected the monarchy
through all the vicissitudes of the last
seven decades
and helped to modernize and continually
to adapt an institution
that is above politics that incarnates
our history and that is indisputably
vital
to the balance and happiness of our
natural
of our national life
by his tireless unstinting
service to the queen the commonwealth
the armed forces the environment
to millions of young people and not so
young people
around the world and to countless other
causes
he gave us and he gives us all
a model of selflessness and of putting
others
before ourselves and
though i suspect mr speaker that he
might be embarrassed
or even faintly exasperated to receive
these tributes
he made this country a better place
and for that he will be remembered with
gratitude
and with fondness for generations to
come